In the world of communication, we have
two dominant approaches. Monologue and
dialogue. And they both have implications for how we come across as leaders. So
let's discuss these and unpack the
details.
Hello again, friends. Alex Lyon here.
This channel, Communication Coach,
is here for rising leaders like you.
All the videos here are to help you increase your personal impact so you can lead the
people around you to higher levels of
excellence. And so if you haven't yet
subscribed, I encourage you to do so. Now a big part of leadership is your
communication style. Are you more likely
to monologue with people or dialogue.
A monologue is where you communicate in a one-way fashion, where you mostly talk
at other people, not with other people.
When you're monologuing, there's not a lot
of invitation to exchange ideas or for
them to take a turn and check for
understanding. Typically the goal of a
monologue whether you realize it or not
is you're trying to get your idea into
the other person's head. So that's one
approach now generally speaking people
don't really like to be on the receiving
end of a monologue. It tends to push
people away. The next time they see you
coming it's very likely that they'll try
to avoid you at least I probably
would. So second, let's look at the
dialogue approach to communication.
A dialogue is by definition two ways.
There's lots of turn-taking lots of
invitation going back and forth in the
conversation both verbally and
non-verbally. The goal of this is not to
implant your idea into somebody else's
head, but instead to reach a mutual
understanding or a shared meaning. Now
that does not mean that you agree with
what the other person is saying and
they've convinced you. You just
understand where they're coming from and
you can appreciate their point of view
in an accurate sense. So at least you do
clearly follow what they're saying. Now
somewhere along the line you're probably
going to run into a clever salesperson
or somebody who really has some
experience. And they will be monologuing at you but they're still doing this
thing where they're taking turns.
It seems like there's some
invitation. You're having a conversation
but in the end they're steering you
toward their desired outcome. I've had
a lot of skilled salespeople drive me
toward their way of thinking. So they're
still trying to get their idea into my
head and that's still a monologue, what
Martin Buber calls a "Monologue disguised
as a dialogue." So when I ask you do are
you more likely to monologue or a
dialogue, I'm talking about a dialogue in
the genuine sense where you actually
desire a mutual exchange of ideas. So,
question of the day.
Are you a "monologue-er" or a "dialogue-er"? I hope I'm saying that right. I would
love to hear your questions/comments in that section below. So, thanks. God bless. And I
will see you next time.